je m'appelle Alain j'ai 27 ans et je me
prostiue depuis 2 ans et
demi comment vous êtes arrivé à la
prostitution peu par hasard par hasard
en même temps c'est voulu mais par
hasard c'est pas vraiment
prémédité c'est-à-dire la première fois
par exemple la première fois que ça
s'est passé comment ça s'est passé B la
première fois je suis allé
à Porte
Dauphine je connaissais une fois j'étais
allé une fois avant pour voir par
curiosité en fait c'est cette curiosité
qui m'a amené à je me suis dit pourquoi
pas quoi à l'époque j'avais des
problèmes de fric bon c'est vrai que
c'est un peu la facilité on va bien voir
je ne savais pas du tout si j'avais la
tête de l'emploi et cetera quoi mais bon
je suis la première fois ça marché
puis vous PZ on pas déranger plus que ça
quoi de vous voulez dire que vous l'avez
fait facilement je l'ai fait assez
facilement
oui pas facilement et donc voilà j'ai
commencé comme ça c'est vraiment le
désir d'argent qui vous a
motivé c'est la première motivation en
effet ouais
mais qu'il y a aussi un peu de plaisir
quelque part ce côté caché des choses
qui qui m'attiraient aussi je sais pas
pourquoi quand vous dites caché
c'est-à-dire l'interdiction dit Oui puis
bon c'est l'inconnu qu on rencontre des
gens qu'on ne connaît pas d'abord qu'on
il y a pas de de contact préalable et
cetera quoi donc c'est sur ce côté un
peu inconnu des choses qui
est excitant quelque part je dirais
quoi est-ce que vous voulez dire par là
que vous trouvez du plaisir dans la
prostitution oui je trouve du plaisir
heureusement je sais qu'il en a qui en
trouve pas de plaisir et je ça doit pas
être facile quand même moi je sais pas
pourquoi je trouve un plaisir avec tous
les clients non pas avec
tous je dire je sais pas moi deux fois
sur trois tant que ça oui tant que ça
enfin c'est un chiffre balance comme
ça vous êtes nombreux là autour du parc
ouais ben ce soir oui bien je sais pas
une vingtaine à peu
près
m'intéresse pas tellement les autres en
fait moi je suis là pour moi pour gagner
du
fris c'est tout
quoi le sida vous y pensez oui tout le
monde comme tout le monde non tout le
monde n'y pense pas moi j'y pense si
quand même quand même beaucoup de mec
dire pas forcément la prostitution mais
dans le milieu en général qui sont
complètement inconscients quoi ser à
quelqu'un euh pour peu qu'on on para on
paraisse en bonne santé machin et cetera
quoi je veux dire la personne s'arrête à
ça quoi il y a pas il y a pas il y a pas
une peur de
ça vous avez fait des tests pardon vous
avez fait des tests
[Musique]
ouais et alors et alors votre avis je
sais pas
bah tout va bien
voilà vous en fait en fin de compte
votre seul fantasme c'était vous
prostituz si je comprends bien
ou je sais pas mon seul
fantasme un fantasme
oui depuis que vous prostiuez c'estd
depuis 2 ans vous avez des petits
copains à côté j'ai beaucoup d'aventure
en
plus ça n'a rien perturbé dans votre vie
privée parce que ça change quand
quelqu'un vous demande qu'est-ce que
vous faites dans la vie
quoi qu'est-ce que vous dites j'avvente
n'importe quoi je dis rien mais je dis
pas je suis gigolo j'arrive à faire
abstraction quand quand je suis avec mes
amis quand j'y pense pas à ça bon j'y
pense un petit peu c'est sûr mais ça me
ça ne rentre pas dans ma vie je ne vis
pas avec ça en fait c'est chose à part
c'estour quand vous faites l'amour au
momentù vous faites l'amour dans votre
vie privée vous n'y pensez pas tu penses
pas heureusement enfin heureusement en
fait je pense peut-être
plus quand je travaille quand je suis
avec un client à comment je fais l'amour
dans ma vie privée que le contraire
certainement plus c'est quoi la
différence avec quand vous êtes
amoureux non
mais je sais pas c'est un plaisir qu'on
a du mal à expliquer c'est qu'on est
bien avec quelqu'un c'est qu'on a envie
d'être à côté c'est qu'on a envie de le
voir on a envie de le toucher et cetera
dans la prostitution c'est pas c'est pas
forcément ça c'est en fait un plaisir on
n pas obligé de regarder ou moi j'ai
souvent les yeux fermés par exemple
quand j'ai des relations avec avec les
clients je ferme les yeux je sais pas
pourquoi on me dit des fois mais
pourquoi tu fermes les yeux fermes
toujours les yeux c'est comme
ça donc c'est
vraiment vous n'avez pas envie de voir
donc vous le faites
pas aussi facilement que
ça non certainement
oui quand vous êtes amourux vous faites
l'amour vous avez les yeux
fermés j'ai les yeux ouverts j'ai les
yeux fermés donc donc je les ouvre là
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
mireuma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche